now let me ask you this before the fox
unwinded you mean I got fired yes did
you think you like were you Ardent like
go fox go guy or do my view on Fox
hasn't really changed they let me say
whatever I want whatever I wanted really
for 14 years and I I'll never stopped
being grateful for that and then
obviously I said too much and I'm not
exactly sure what I said that was bad no
one ever told me but one day they're
like Noe can't have this anymore and
they fired me and I even told them as
they were firing me like your business I
made a b toone never work for anyone
else again and and I never will our view
on the war in Ukraine was really really
hated I could feel it and my view was
not pro Russia never has been Pro Russia
I also thought it was interesting that
what Tucker said there was that he will
never have another boss